surfant sur un vélo fait coup on a
l'impression de se sentir comme une mise
en scène de vélo d'annick et gaudreault
acquiert depuis trois mois de nouvelles
compétences chez action sport vélo un
organisme avec une double mission
environnementale et sociale you juste la
chambre à air a changé puis enlever la
rouille
le laver vingt-cinq mille vélos ont été
recyclées depuis 2005 grâce aux trois
points de service de l'organisme à
windsor valcourt et actuelle près de
4000 bicyclette on peut être remonter et
revendu les vélos irrécupérable ont été
démontées 750 mes livres d'assister
s'ils étaient détournés des sites
d'enfouissement
impressionnant des quantités qu'on
puisse et qu'on peut récupérer et ben
ouais l'idée de leur donner une deuxième
vie aussi c'est quand même assez
intéressant pour les gens qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens sont achetés 1 2 ce
qui étonne aussi yoann denoual formateur
au point de service de windsor c'est de
voir les changements qui s'opèrent chez
les jeunes adultes qui vivent ici une
initiation à l'emploi
les progressions les plus
impressionnantes c'est en terme de
confiance en soi que ce soit au niveau
mécanique ou social avec des clients
c'est pas mal ça le plus impressionnant
je dirais dont je suis le plus content
délicat et thomas fontaine trouve ici de
nouvelles motivations leur stage doit
durer trente semaines si on veut quelque
chose pour de se décourager puis de
contenus 6 3 devant pour donner l'étape
décisive pour savoir vers où je m'en
vais avec cet âge là j'apprends j'ai
appris que j'aimais beaucoup la
mécanique la black mécanique que je me
répète ce contenu en mécanique auto ou à
la petite mécanique genre tronçonneuse
coûte moto quant au jeune samuel la
course âgée de 13 ans il participe à un
programme de 80 heures qui lui procure
une première expérience de travail
j'aime avant le travail des coupes c'est
comme la famille
qu'est-ce qu'il va naître
on semble trop seul pit lane à l'expo ce
pays depuis 2005 320 jeunes adultes ont
réalisé un stage chez action sport vélo
soixante dix pour cent d'entre eux ont
trouvé ensuite un autre emploi ou sont
retournés aux études et si guilhem
charest trader et matin à windsor